the reality on the ground is that
everyone knows this country is being
invaded and everyone knows it is
intentional right let's let's just
remember the reason that this is
happening is because Texas decided to
stop it from happening right that's what
happened Texas said we're going to put
up some of that barbed wire and then the
federal government was like no no we
don't like barbed wire uh here's a
little bit of video of the Texas
National Guard actually being deployed
at the
border
those are good decent Americans the
members of the Texas National Guard
doing what is right for their state and
they are only doing it because for for
months now the federal government has
not done anything about it actually the
federal government has gone out of its
way to make sure that as Greg Abbott
pointed out 6 million people in three
months uh sorry 6 million people in
three years do you realize how crazy
that is as he points out that's over the
population of 33 states that is
completely untenable that is how you
destroy a nation from the inside uh
here's a bit more of what the Texas
National Guard is doing right as we
speak right this very moment in Texas to
hold its line uh in its standoff with
the federal government you might note
barbed wire because apparently it
actually does
[Music]
work
you know I got nicked on barbed wire
once you guys ever get into a little
barbed wire ever happened to you I used
to go play basketball at this court that
was owned by like some company and a
bunch of us in high school used to play
at this court and we had to hop a fence
to get onto this court it was super nice
court and then eventually they put barb
wire there and I got my leg cut on
Barbed I probably have a scar actually
maybe we'll show it to you tomorrow
different type of show but maybe we'll
do that because barbed wire works for
example uh these guys all work at my
house every day that's where we shoot
the show uh there's a code at the door
that opens the gate for them if I was to
disable that code and just put barbed
wire there instead would you find that
more difficult or easier to get in more
difficult that's why he gets paid yeah
you get it you guys get
it